le salaire universel on m'a fait des
expérimentés mais je crois qu'il ne faut
pas anticiper trop il faut pas exagérer
les avantages d'abord parce que même
s'il ya des gens qui pensent que l'on
peut remplacer tous les autres systèmes
de sécurité sociale avec le sahara vers
l'universel dans ce cas là le niveau des
salaires universelle doit être très
élevé et ça doit être ça devient trop
cher et c'est pour ce soir qui si elle
introduit un système de salaire
universel ça va augmenter le système
avec une nouvel élément dans les
complexités qui est déjà considérable
deuxièmement on dit que ça va être plus
facile pour les gens d'accepter du
travail parce que le système universel
c'est l'inversé il va diminuer l'impôt
d'impôt etc
c'est vrai il y un problème là mais ça
aura nouveau on peut le résoudre un
autre moyen on peut réduire la fiscalité
sur les salaires bas et on peut aussi
créer un système dans lequel les
salariés de maintenir un certain système
de certains avantages sociaux assistance
sociale même si le travail pour une
semaine deux semaines quelque chose et
ça ça peut faciliter l'intégration du
genre dans les marchés du travail c'est
à dire d'autre mais un troisième à moi
je pense que quand même dans notre
société avec un état provincial qui a
c'est assez considérable énième
obligation morale je dirais pour chacun
d'essayer quand même de contribuer à la
fonctionnement d'une société à la
financement du secteur public m
n'aime pas cette idée que chacun peut
justement rester à la maison parce que
c'est pour les autres que j'en ai payé 1
s'avère universel irrité accepter cette
idée mais mon patron et dès les essais d
expérimenter voyons qu est ce que ça va
donner